звертаюся до президента Зеленського
особисто пам'ятайте як ми з Марусею Вам
казали що відводити війська не можна бо
це небезпека пам'ятаєте як ми казали що
військовим хамети не можна військових
треба поважати тому що це небезпека
Пам'ятайте як ви проти нас розпочали
кримінальну справу і по суті ви
закрутили оцей виржахливих подій з
переслідуваннями військових у вас
сьогодні якщо ви дійсно прозріли 24
лютого 22-го року є нагода позакривати
ці справи Не інспірувати і дати наказ
своїм шафкам в офісі руки геть а служби
безпеки руки затих шапок які зараз
розповсюджують оці оці справи насправді
військові єдині хто я гарантом вашої
безпеки військові єдині хто є гарантом
нашого життя і з такими справами ви
робите все щоби військові зненавиділи
вас усіма можливими фібрами душі